l'histoire retient les grands hommes et
si pour une fois on s'intéressait à ces
Français qui n'ont pas de rue à leur nom
vous voyez Léon Blum et bien moi c'est
elle qui m'intéresse qui est-elle au
milieu de tous ces hommes et là derrière
Sartre qu'avait-il à dire ce jour-là et
derrière Piaf lui c'est qui j'ai envie
de retracer leur vie leur arbre
généalogique de fouiller dans les
archives retrouvez la famille de ses
anonymes qui mérite d'être connu des
gens ordinaires au destin extraordinaire
et si pour une fois c'était leur
histoire qu'on vous raconter
[Musique]
j'aimerais d'abord savoir ce qui vous a
conduit au bal je fais des cambriolages
et autrefois vous savez c'était pas
comme aujourd'hui la décoration était
dur quel âge vous aviez à l'époque
vous pensez que vous avez mérité ces
années de balle je trouve j'ai mérité
une punition mais je trouve que les
années de bains ont été exagérées
combien d'années de balles plus 50
doublages avaient 10 ans alors vous
écrivez que votre vie a été une longue
suite d'aventure extraordinaire c'est
vrai alors je me suis évadé quatre fois
[Musique]
cet archive de 1977 je l'ai trouvé en
cherchant un bagnard dont je pourrais
vous raconter l'histoire
l'avis de Raymond Vaudé ressemble à un
incroyable polar avant de se confier à
la télé c'est dans un livre qu'il a
raconté sa rocambolesque évasion du
bagne de Guyane et puis il y a cette
photo qui m'intrigue en 1964 un anonyme
pose à côté du général de Gaulle c'est
Raymond Vaudé mais par quel mystère lui
l'ancienne ennemi public peut-il se
retrouver aux côtés du Président de la
République
qu'a-t-il bien pu faire pour se racheter
de ses crimes des crimes qui l'ont
précipité dans l'enfer du bagne
[Musique]
c'est ça le camp là
derrière le mur là
donc là on arrive à l'embarcadère
exactement comme La Martinière arriva en
1935 avec vodabord il reste pas grand
chose mais c'est là
c'est à bord du navire La Martinière que
Raymond Vaudé débarque en Guyane à
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni en septembre
1935 avec ses compagnons d'infortune
Vaudé a fait la quasi-totalité de sa
peine en métropole il pense avoir
échappé aux bagnes
raté la justice française l'envoie en
Guyane pour purger les 67 derniers jours
de sa peine
des surveillants appelés nos noms et
trois groupes se former
le premier 112 hommes étaient composés
de prisonniers si dangereux qu'il serait
dirigé sur une île
dans le second était les hommes
susceptibles d'amendement selon la
formule administrative
dans le troisième ce qu'une conduite
parfaitement sage avait désignée à la
confiance de l'administration
pénitentiaire
[Musique]
j'appartenais à la deuxième section moi
le Vaudé au 122 jours de cachot
en passant sous ce porche en septembre
1935 je devins le matricule 5230
donc ils arrivent là ils arrivent là
encadrer par les forces de l'ordre
ils sont pas enfermés la journée ils ont
des activités du travaux forcés même je
dirais tout le monde quitte la prison la
journée c'est vide ici c'est vide
le bagne de Guyane c'est une idée de
Napoléon III l'esclavage vient d'être
aboli et il a besoin de bras pour
développer sa colonie alors en 1854
finit Brest ou Toulon pour les condamner
aux travaux forcés désormais voleur
faussaire et criminels iront travailler
gratuitement à 8000 km de l'Hexagone
[Musique]
et dans des conditions terribles presque
inhumaines le climat tropical la chaleur
l'humidité les maladies la fièvre jaune
la malaria
être envoyée Aubagne c'est une
condamnation à mort qui ne dit pas son
nom
l'espérance de vie ne dépasse pas 3 à 5
ans
le bagne on le surnomme la guillotine
sèche parce qu'il tue comme la
guillotine mais ne fait pas couler de
sang
[Musique]
c'est difficile d'imaginer mais on est
dans un des baraquements où vivent les
bagnards alors là faut imaginer un
système de hamac mais tendu vraiment à
l'horizontale ce qui fait que chaque
homme avait quand même un petit espace
vital il faut imaginer des planches en
bois tout le long pour poser ses
affaires principalement de quoi manger
la petite gamelle la cuillère
il s'est retrouvé ici au milieu de
60 70 80 bonhommes
inconnu de lui la plupart
pour les rebelles et les Grandes Gueules
direction le quartier disciplinaire où
l'on purge sa punition en cellule
individuelle ou collective
allongé
là par exemple c'est un lit sur lequel
on passe la nuit les pieds attachés à la
barre avec 10 autres détenus
[Musique]
les bailleurs qui arrivent ici en
général ils arrivent pour quel type de
crime en général ici c'est plutôt
des criminels des violeurs des fausses
parce que mon vaudet c'est un voleur lui
la différence à la sortie à la sortie tu
vois que tu es libérée que tu veux tu
veux essayer de survivre de gagner ta
vie que tu es soumis au doublage donc tu
dois rester en Guyane on va facilement
plus embaucher un transporté même si la
tuer quelqu'un qu'un voleur récidiviste
ah ouais ça c'est c'est certifié par
tout le monde parce qu'on se dit en gros
un type qui a tué tu auras pas forcément
un type qui a volé il revolvera
exactement
le bail ne commence à réellement pour
moi qu'après le 67e jour exactement le
27 novembre 1935
j'étais désormais un libérée qui
commençait son temps de doublage et qui
devait subvenir seul à tous ses besoins
le doublage une peine atroce une double
peine résumée en moins de deux lignes
dans le code pénal de l'époque
tout individu sera tenu à l'expiration
de sa peine de résider dans la colonie
pendant un temps égal à la durée de sa
condamnation
[Musique]
le but de la loi que les mauvais
éléments une fois libérés finissent leur
vie en Guyane et ne rentrent jamais en
métropole
[Musique]
les anciens bagnards air alors comme des
fantômes dans le village délibéré
[Musique]
encore vivant dans la ville il y a
encore des années 70 années 80 et donc
on vivait au milieu de la population on
commence à marcher on savait exactement
qui était libéré qu'il n'était pas voilà
il y avait vraiment la population libre
et la population délibé nous dit pas
précisément où il a vécu une fois qu'il
était libéré on n'a pas l'adresse mais
on sait que c'était chez un libéré donc
potentiellement dans une de ces maisons
des murs délabrés des toitures crevées
des portes ouvertes sur des ombres
sordides
dans les ruelles souillées des hommes
déchirés avec des yeux sournois
sur les 4000 libérés 1500 à peine avait
trouvé à s'employé il s'accrochait à
leur place comme des tiques à la peau
pour la garder ils étaient capables de
n'importe quoi de balayer les ordures
avec la langue ou de [__] un coup de
couteau
j'en connais qui se sont fait passer
exprès en train de voler ou même de tuer
pour rentrer au bagne et bouffer à leur
faim
[Musique]
Raymond Vaudé n'a plus qu'une seule idée
en tête s'évader
trois fois la première fois il a été en
face
il arrive de nuit il est tout seul
ah oui d'accord il a besoin de personne
il a payé il a payé le pire il se
débrouille après au Suriname ça marche
pas très bien bon on le retrouve il est
voilà il est ramené
l'officier ne pouvait m'autoriser à ses
journées sur le territoire hollandais
mais pour m'épargner la punition des
autorités françaises il me permettait de
revenir secrètement à Saint-Laurent la
deuxième fois il suit des chercheurs
d'or là l'idée c'est de descendre le
Maroni
laisser les chercheurs d'or continuer
tout seul arriver au mont tumultimate et
passer par le Brésil
[Musique]
cette première journée fut heureuse et
facile la forêt ne m'avait pas repoussé
le sixième jour une piqûre soudaine un
coup d'aiguille profonde une chose
animale
le 14e jour les plaies de mes jambes
étaient changées en ulcère qui
commençait à saigner
34 rien qu'à la jambe gauche
le 25e jour la fièvre m'écrasait et
j'étais ravagée de dysenterie
la forêt était la plus forte
je fermais les yeux et je pensais que
plus jamais je ne les rouvrirai
[Musique]
mon radeau du cuivre le courant je
traversais la brousse ces silences et
ses cris
[Musique]
elle me rejetait
des chercheurs d'or qui descendaient le
Maroni m'aperçu et me transportèrent à
l'hôpital
puisque j'avais été trouvé sur le
territoire de la colonie j'étais présumé
dans n'être jamais sorti et n'avoir pas
tenté de m'évader je peux donc rentrer
au village
la troisième fois était la bonne cette
fois-ci on est parti par là il est parti
par là
il a réussi
[Musique]
le périple de Raymond Vaudé va durer 8
mois une évasion impossible sans
quelques complices haut placé des
fonctionnaires étrangers révoltés par le
sort inhumain que réserve alors la
France à ses bagnards à Trinidad le
gouverneur de Lille l'aide à réparer sa
pirogue fracassée par la tempête à
Sainte-Lucie c'est le chef de la police
qui lui permet de charger sa pirogue à
bord d'un bateau pour éviter une
arrestation en Martinique ou en
Guadeloupe deux mois et demi après son
départ il est accueilli en héros sur les
îles Vierges britanniques
puis écroué à Porto Rico où on le prend
pour un contrebandier c'est un diplomate
américain qui le fait libérer sous les
hourras de la foule l'aventure de
Raymond Vaudé a fait le tour des
Caraïbes et elle ne fait que commencer
je calculais que j'avais quitté
Saint-Laurent depuis 5 mois et une
semaine plus de 3000 km en mer et
combien d'autres encore à parcourir
attaqué par les requins tenaillé par la
faim vos dés finit par s'échouer sur les
récifs de Jamaïque avant de rejoindre
Panama et dit embarquer clandestinement
sur un bateau en partance pour la France
le 23 avril 1938 il arrive à
Saint-Nazaire et on lui attend de pied
ferme
l'inspecteur commençait à monter un
escalier 3 et j'étais déjà loin de lui
j'accédais à un pont et continuer de
courir l'eau si lointaine et si noire je
franchis le bordage et mélancée comme
d'un toit
vaudez échappent à la police
mais pourquoi prend-il tous les risques
pour rentrer en métropole
il semble animé par un désir de
vengeance
calèche faire acheter ce revolver ou
accepter tous les coups sans les avoir
rendus
[Musique]
mais ce venger de qui de ceux qui l'ont
envoyé au bagne il est temps d'enquêter
sur son passé de criminel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour Thomas je suis content
de vous rencontrer et ben moi aussi ça
me fait très plaisir ça va bien ouais ça
va Franck sénateur le plus grand
spécialiste français du bagne Nathan aux
archives de la Seine à Paris bonjour on
travaille sur un bagnard
l'idéal ça serait qu'on arrive à trouver
le dossier de procédure pour l'année de
sa condamnation donc c'est 1933
vous auriez ça super
là c'est le dossier de procédure complet
c'est génial ça c'est très intéressant
parce qu'on s'aperçoit qu'il fait partie
d'une bande
Jules tondu
la bande attendue voilà est tendue donc
c'est le c'est le chef de bande 12
condamnations
vaudait donc vol qualifier tentative de
vol qualifié et c'est génial ça il
repérait des maisons isolées et
inhabitées et elle a tombé de la nuit
ils opèrent pénétrant par effraction en
portant du numéraire du linge de
l'argenterie etc il visite également la
cave et se restaurer il fallait prendre
des forces c'est normal
et donc il a fait l'objet de deux
rapports médicaux légaux quand même
[Musique]
en 1932 trois ans avant son départ pour
la Guyane Raymond Vaudé plaide le coup
de folie mais ne trompe pas l'expert
médical qui le trouve calme et lucide
exempt de tout délire ne présentant pas
d'affaiblissement intellectuel démentiel
la justice qualifie Raymond Vaudé de
redoutable malfaiteur
très dangereux et le condamne à 5 ans de
travaux forcés plus 5 ans de doublage en
Guyane
le bagne permet d'éloigner pour toujours
ce qu'on considère comme irrécupérable
et Raymond Vaudé en fait visiblement
partie
[Musique]
mais toujours aucune piste pour
expliquer son retour
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi ça tatoué sur les bras
ah ça c'est intéressant femme chinoise
en couleur sur les bras et tête de femme
grandeur naturel sur la poitrine donc le
type a un tatouage et ça j'imagine que
c'est essentiel pour la police de
les bagnards étaient tous tatoués et
chaque tatouage avait une signification
bien précise
les tatouages de Raymond Vaudé
contiennent peut-être un indice une clé
pour m'aider à comprendre son désir de
vengeance
cette tête de femme chinoise m'intrigue
[Musique]
je contacte le spécialiste du tatouage
et du grand banditisme allô
des années 20 qui est aussi un tatoué
les années 20 et donc forcément je suis
arrivé à vous
parler moi monsieur
vous empêcher un copain qui est à Poissy
en histoire du tatouage
[Musique]
Michael de Poissy n'est pas qu'une star
du tatouage c'est aussi un grand
collectionneur
[Musique]
voici l'un de ses trésors
des plaques de verre avec des clichés
anthropométriques de détenus du début du
20e siècle c'est hyper beau enfin le
simple document lui-même oui c'est assez
rare maintenant les plaques de verre
semblablement des photos prises par un
médecin alors c'est l'équipe quand il
est arrêté en gros lors de la regarder
on les immortalisait on sent le médecin
qui essaie de comprendre
rien et c'est ça le truc
[Musique]
c'est moi un peu fatigué et avec des
tatouages et avec des tatouages de
bagnards
[Musique]
les détenus se font tatouer selon une
codification précise
un croissant de lune avec un chat noir
et une lanterne suspendue c'est que vous
êtes passé devant le conseil de guerre
un papillon ça signifie comme lui je
vole
et le poignard là c'est la vengeance
vers le haut je me vengerai vers le bas
comme ici je me suis vengé mais les
bagnards aiment aussi les rébus faciles
comme j'ai le cafard
[Musique]
fatalité c'est le mauvais destin celui
qui vous envoie au bagne justement
[Musique]
mon problème c'est que ça ressemble pas
du tout au grand tatouage que Raymond
Vaudé a sur le torse
des années 30 d'accord et donc on nous
apprend
là on n'a pas de photo malheureusement
de voder mais qu'il a une tête de femme
grandeur naturelle donc là taille réelle
et sur les bras des têtes de femmes
chinoises en couleur
pas tellement un tatouage de prison
parce que
s'il y a de la couleur c'est un premier
indice pourquoi en gros parce que le
tatouage de prison s'était fait ce qu'on
appelle du noir de fumée donc
généralement les tatouages ils sont
monochromes ils sont en noir qui devient
un peu bleu après là on peut supposer si
tu as un tatouage qui a été fait pour un
professionnel et non pas au fond d'une
cellule c'est validée
la taille de la tête aussi c'est quand
même assez rare vraiment pour pas dire
quasiment introuvable et les voyous
français ou les bagnards etc ça faisait
rarement des femmes chinoises plutôt ça
sent l'escale dans un port asiatique ça
sent l'escale c'est donc fait tatouer
avant le bagne pendant son service
militaire on sait qu'il a été marrant
bon nous ça tombe bien et qu'il a fait
partie d'une grande expédition en 1922 à
bord du Jules Michelet et le jus
Michelet fait escale effectivement dans
l'océan Indien
quelques années après son retour du
service militaire Raymond Vaudé se fait
tirer le portrait sur cette photo de
1931 il a 29 ans être voyou dans les
années fin des années 20 des années 30
c'est pas être voyou en 1900 c'est alors
là on est on est dans une période
charnière de la criminalité française il
y a une sophistication dans le crime il
y a des outils qui apparaissent il y a
des pistolets qui permettent de faire
des braquages des voitures qui
permettent de s'enfuir
au cinéma il va regarder la presse et
puis il va se dire on va essayer de
ressembler à quelque chose et donc
c'était américain
alors bagouse aux doigts
sur l'oeil etc etc vraiment Vaudé il
entre vraiment dans la marge par du vol
en 1929 il a 27 28 ans
avançant on lui connaît pas de méfait
particulier est-ce que c'est tard pour
ah oui c'est très tard parce que
généralement quand on était voyou à
l'époque on était très jeune et il y
avait une espèce de terminus social quoi
grandissait dans les dans la zone dans
les faubourgs et puis on embrasse la
carrière assez rapidement donc vous
venez on peut imaginer plutôt qu'il a
basculé à la suite d'un drame une
rupture quelque chose qui fait qui va
tomber dans la marge se désociabiliser
donc pour comprendre pourquoi il est
tombé là dedans mais si j'ai bien
compris il faut aller rechercher dans sa
vie personnelle oui il faut voir dans
son parcours quelle rupture il a pu
connaître à ce moment-là pour basculer
ce désociabiliser tout lâcher et partir
dans les bas-fonds
c'est à virer souba ou voder à passer la
première partie de sa vie que je vais
comprendre le drame qu'il a fait
basculer dans la délinquance
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes Monsieur le Maire non
je suis le secrétaire numérique
ça tombe bien parce que je cherche des
informations sur la famille d'un des
administrés de la ville Raymond Vaudé
alors on avait dit 1902 vraiment beau
marier à 3 le 22 août 1925 avec Solange
Louise aéromé à trois le 30 avril 1940
avec Lucie Marie-Madeleine
est décédée
le voilà le tournant personnel sa
première femme Solange décède en 1929
c'est à ce moment-là que sa vie bascule
à ce drame personnel s'ajoute l'absence
d'avenir chez lui Aviré son père et sa
mère sont ouvriers dans cette immense
filature
mais après la guerre de 14 ce fleuron
français de l'industrie textile est en
difficulté
le travail se fait rare
Raymond trouve bien un emploi de garçons
de café mais se pose des questions sur
son avenir au village et puis il a
rencontré une nouvelle femme ensemble
des argentés ils décident de tenter
l'aventure dans la capitale
le pari des années 20 c'est les années
folles la ville de tous les possibles
[Musique]
alors venez il arrive de virer sous
barre avec sa nouvelle compagne il rêve
du pari des années folles du Moulin
Rouge c'est pas très loin le pari des
cabarets etc le Paris qui brille et puis
il arrive ici il a atterrit ici c'est un
autre pari c'est le pari des bas-fonds
on est rue de la Goutte d'Or devant le
11 c'est l'hôtel dans lequel il
s'installe c'est un hôtel qui est aussi
un hôtel de passe en réalité on le voit
dans les archives avec des prostituées
un peu partout oh le petit de la rue de
la
[Musique]
à la Guyane dans la savane ça lui
bouillonne le cerveau mais quand il
arrive ici lui au départ en tout cas à
croire un peu les rapports d'instruction
et ce qui peut nous raconter il veut
réussir il veut travailler
oui oui il va travailler un peu
d'ailleurs il va travailler dans une
entreprise juste à côté d'ici la rénovex
qui est une société nettoyage
malheureusement il va faire la rencontre
qu'il fallait pas c'est Salins l'un des
membres éminents de la banque attendu
qu'on a découvert ensemble dans les
archives à Paris il y a quelques temps
et c'est lui qui va repérer ce type
c'est un gars qui doit être un peu perdu
vos dés à ce moment-là il arrive pas à
joindre les deux boules les salaires on
peut imaginer que c'est quand même des
des salaires de misère et ça va être la
tentation de l'argent facilement et puis
salam encore une fois c'est pas le c'est
pas le grand luxe du grand banditisme
donc il lui promet pas tu vois des
villas et des belles bagnoles et et
c'est juste pour pour arriver à vivoter
à se sentir un peu mieux c'est les coups
facile c'est des des maisons vides
deserté voilà des maisons secondaires
donc l'autre lui dit bon écoute c'est
pas compliqué on rentre la nuit on fait
un freak tu vois on pète la porte une
fenêtre et puis on a le receleur qui est
derrière le lendemain on a de l'argent
tu vois donc ça parait ça paraît facile
il le propose pas de braquer une banque
évidemment ouais on n'est pas à ce
niveau là on est vraiment chez les
petits criminels
dans la France de l'antre de guerre la
politique pénale ne pardonne aucun écart
un apprenti cambrioleur comme Raymond
Vaudé peut finir Aubagne avec l'idée
qu'il ne remette plus jamais les pieds
en métropole c'est pourtant ce qu'il
parvient à faire grâce à sa
rocambolesque évasion 7 ans plus tard
alors la franque changement d'époque
changement de quartier dans le quartier
de l'Opéra c'est beaucoup plus chic on
est en 1938 à la fin du mois d'avril
vodait a fait sa partie sa période de
bagne il s'est enfui
il a sauté dans l'eau à Saint-Nazaire il
est en cavale et il donne rendez-vous à
la fin du mois d'avril 1938 un
journaliste de Paris Soir voilà ici au
Café de la Paix
pourquoi
donne-t-il rendez-vous à la presse alors
que la police ne cherche partout oui
c'est drôle cet exercice de comme
finalement
parce que il va il va se justifier dans
cet article là quand même clairement
j'aimais une femme le soir de mon
premier vol elle était à la salle
pétrière elle attendait un enfant un
enfant de moi j'étais sans un sou et
sans travail je ne voulais pas que
sortir de l'hôpital mon gosse et sa mère
soit à la rue
au-delà de la question de l'injustice de
la question affective aussi on sent
quand même en lisant ce que dit vos dés
qu'il est quand même aussi ça aussi un
moment colère et qu'il en veut à
quelqu'un et ce quelqu'un c'est pas
n'importe qui puisque c'est la fameuse
blanche Gauthier donc la mère de son
enfant parce qu'il considère que tous
les drames qu'il a pu connaître
elle en est un peu responsable
[Musique]
pour cette femme après j'ai continué
d'autres cambriolages pendant quelques
mois et puis le 27 novembre 1930 je me
fais prendre c'est elle qui m'avait
donné la veille elle avait passé la nuit
avec le policier qui devait
m'appréhender
une version accrédité par le dossier
d'instruction et confirmé par un membre
de la bande attendue qui s'est confié à
vos dés dans les coulisses de leur
procès
depuis elle ne m'a jamais donné de
nouvelles de mon fils elle m'a
simplement écrit une lettre d'un jujure
je n'oublierai jamais il est persuadé
que elle a chargé au maximum auprès de
la police quand il a été arrêté et à
quel couché en plus avec le commissaire
voilà alors là donc là c'est sûr que
c'est pardonnable chargé oui sûrement
parce que c'est vrai qu'encore une fois
cette condamnation de 50 travaux forcés
pour quelques cambriolages sur une
période de deux mois c'est dur quand on
voit voilà quand on voit le le
butin le le qui est rapporté c'est quand
même une peine qui est lourde quoi et on
a l'impression en lisant l'article il va
il va vouloir se venger donc il va
monter qui va remonter à 3 pour
finalement pour pour se venger et lui
faire la peau quoi
voici maintenant 7 ans que cette femme
hante mon cerveau pendant ma détention
elle n'a pas quitté mon esprit une
minute une seule seconde mes nuits de
Força furent hanté de sa présence et les
lois n'auront rien à voir dans ma
vengeance
quand l'article paraît la police elle a
tous les éléments qu'on vient d'évoquer
elle lit ça c'est quasiment fini enfin
la police c'est à peu près où il va
aller est-ce qu'il risque de faire c'est
étonnant d'ailleurs tu vois parce que
bon il est seul il a pas de moyen il a
sauté du bateau Saint-Nazaire dans la
merde donc on voit bien que il a rien
quoi il a pas de logistique c'est la fin
de la cavale c'est presque désespéré
comme geste en fait
la cavale de Raymond Vaudé c'est un
formidable feuilleton pour la presse de
l'époque qui détaille par le menu le
jour où il s'invite chez blanche-gautier
leur fils est bien là mais pas son
ex-compagne il était venu embrasser son
fils qu'il n'avait jamais vu
l'enfant lève une figure étonnée l'homme
maintenant le fixe longuement
silencieusement comme s'il voulait à
jamais imprimer en lui cette vision mais
déjà le père se penche à la fenêtre la
rue est pleine de traquenard il fait
nuit il ne faut pas perdre une minute
sur l'ordre du commandant de gendarmerie
des barrages avaient été établi hier
soir sur la route de Paris car on se
doutait qu'il tenterait de regagner la
capitale
[Musique]
j'ai l'honneur de vous faire connaître à
toute fin utile que le transporter
libéré Vaudé Raymond a été arrêté le 29
avril 1938 à Nogent-sur-Seine
Raymond Vaudé affirme avoir finalement
renoncé à sa vengeance je sais bien
qu'on a peur de moi mais je ne suis pas
fou je sors d'en prendre et je n'ai pas
l'intention dire tourner le passé est
mort et je vais me tenir tranquille
ça hantise être renvoyée dans l'enfer du
bagne de Guyane
la suite de l'histoire elle est écrite
noir sur blanc dans son casier
judiciaire conservé aux archives de
l'Aube à trois
juillet 1938
Nogent-sur-Seine alors qu'il avait pris
place dans un camion qui se dirigeait
vers Paris et du coup alors il est
condamné à quoi là dessus 15 jours dans
plusieurs
il restait de toute façon avec la guerre
jusqu'à la fin de la gare ça veut dire
qu'il aurait pu rentrer éventuellement
que après la guerre cette fois-ci la
justice est clémente avec Raymond Vaudé
il a réussi à émouvoir les juges
autre bonne nouvelle pour lui un décret
loi qui met fin Aubagne est publié le 17
juin 1938 un mois avant son procès
un des derniers décrets lois intéressant
les colonies françaises a décidé la
suppression du bagne nous ne verrons
donc plus les luguments qu'on voit de
force acquitter Saint-Martin de Ré à
bord du bateau La Martinière pour aller
peupler les camps en pénitentiaires de
la Guyane un journaliste a joué un rôle
clé pour éveiller les consciences Albert
Londres et son enquête de terrain sur le
bagne choque l'opinion en 1924 et finit
14 ans plus tard par changer le cours de
l'histoire
Raymond Vaudé ne retournera donc pas au
bagne il a désormais une obsession être
réhabilitée
[Musique]
à 3 en 1938 Raymond Vaudé retrouve sa
vie d'homme libre et redevient garçon de
café
mais la guerre vient frapper le destin
de millions de Français dont Raymond
vaudérance nous avons pris des armes
contre l'agression devant l'avancée
allemande des milliers de Troyens fuient
la ville Raymond Vaudé reste et voit sa
ville tombée aux mains des Allemands le
matin du 16 juin 1940
son destin va à nouveau basculer son
histoire va à nouveau se heurter à la
grande histoire
la suite c'est Sébastien touffut un
spécialiste de l'occupation à trois qui
la raconte il a étudié de près le
dossier Raymond Vaudé on en plein centre
de ville de Troyes et c'est ici qui
aurait mon Beaudet va rentrer en
résistance on est en juin 40 et dans les
archives je découvre qu'il est garçons
de café au Café de Paris et j'ai
retrouvé cette carte postale qui a une
des rares cartes postales où l'on voit
la localisation précise du Café de Paris
qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui parce que
la face à nous là
c'est quoi alors on a la Bourse du
Travail donc c'est un bâtiment
emblématique de la Vidéotron qui existe
depuis la fin du 19e siècle il existe
encore oui là on voit bien les maisons
là à côté Arras ça commence à changer un
resto vietnamien qui n'existait pas à
l'époque et
le fameux café Le Café de Paris
alors le bâtiment n'existe plus du tout
mais qui serait là
c'est un café un peu particulier à trois
une histoire particulière parce qu'en
fait sans propriétaire en 1940 va
devenir collaborationniste et c'est l'un
des principaux responsables de la
collaboration au niveau de Davido 3
d'ailleurs il y a plusieurs cafés alors
quand on est garçon de café comme
Raymond baudet
c'est quand même un poste d'observation
extraordinaire alors il rentre en
résistance progressivement mais pour les
réseaux de la résistance un garçon de
café surtout dans un café comme celui-ci
c'est exceptionnel non ah bah c'est
certain parce que évidemment les
personnes qui fréquentent le café par le
trait librement donc il peut saisir les
conversations au vol et puis après on
rendre compte auprès de ses responsables
au sein de la résistance et ce qui est
pas inimaginable c'est qu'il ait été
recruté parce qu'il était garçon de café
et quand lui qui en lui a dit surtout
reste en cette place là non bah tu dois
justement rester au sein de ce café
parce que tu nous seras bien plus utile
au sein de ce café que si par exemple tu
te venais clandestin enfin on a une idée
même assez imprécise du nombre de
résistants dans une ville comme trois
qui compte après 40 000 habitants la
guerre dans ce qu'on appelle la
résistance pionnière vraiment la
résistance des tout début 1940-1942 je
pense simplement quelques dizaines de
résistances il y en a vraiment très très
peu
et Raymond Vaudé en faisait donc partie
il m'a en effet révélé que la femme
Janine court était une indicatrice de la
Gestapo et de la milice
Monsieur Raymond Vaudé m'a également
averti de la collaboration certaine de
Henri holdéric il soupçonnait celui-ci
de l'avoir dénoncé à la Gestapo
donc là on a marché quoi 5 minutes oui à
peine et on se retrouve devant un lieu
très important du 3
occupé pendant la guerre c'est cet hôtel
particulier qui correspond au siège de
la Gestapo
combien de personnes boss là la Gestapo
on a le procès de la Gestapo 3 qui s'est
tenu après-guerre et en fait les membres
de la Gestapo ils sont une poignée ils
sont moins d'une dizaine en fait ce qui
fait leur force sans les informateurs
Français regardent les dizaines de
personnes qui viennent quasiment au
quotidien enseignement avec les
musiciens
et dans les archives qu'on découvre
c'est que l'un de ceux qui les sœurs
seront Vaudé oui parce que la radeau
encore il a cet avantage c'est que il
est considéré comme collaborateur il
fait le travail donc au Café de Paris
donc on a tout confiance en lui et il
vient sans doute à régulièrement aussi
avec de la Gestapo pour servir à la fois
les officiellement et puis le personnel
administratifs c'est fou d'imaginer un
résistant passer les grilles presque de
légèreté de la part de la Gestapo de pas
avoir enquêté sur les gens qui venaient
travailler chez eux quand même oui c'est
totalement étonnant c'est extraordinaire
bien qu'étant un inconnu pour Monsieur
Bodet à cette époque celui-ci m'a caché
hébergé chez lui pendant plusieurs
semaines
Monsieur Raymond Vaudé m'a procuré une
fausse carte d'identité parfaitement en
règle afin que je puisse fuir
donc là on arrive sur un lieu très
particulier et très important pour
l'histoire de Raymond voler de la
résistance on est à l'usine machette
vachette c'est la grande usine de
serrurerie de clés etc c'est une
entreprise très atypique à l'époque
parce que c'est une des rares qui va
résister la particularité de vachette
pendant l'occupation c'est de réaliser
ce qu'on appelle des gaines d'étui pour
les obus qui vont être utilisés par
l'armée allemande d'accord donc c'est
rentrer pour l'effort de guerre allemand
et là l'usine enfin les patrons peuvent
pas dire non mais ils vont tout faire
pour ralentir la production et comme ils
peuvent pas saboter eux-mêmes ça serait
louche le résine bah ils vont appeler
les réseaux de résistants et notamment
notre ami Raymond Vaudé oui la direction
d'établissement va lui demander de
procéder un acte de sabotage contre le
four de l'usine donc c'est un acte de
résistance un peu atypique parce que on
lui ouvre la porte enfin il est aidé en
lui facilite la tâche en tout cas
ça reste quand même un événement très
dangereux très risqué et il risque
beaucoup lui-même ça raconte aussi
l'histoire de voder qui passe de je
transmets de la formation sur ma
terrasse de café a j’agis directement le
sabotage qui a lieu ici même à
l'industrie vachette c'est sans doute
l'un des principaux actes et l'un des
premiers actes qui a lieu au niveau de
l'Aube et d'ailleurs à cette même époque
un peu après Raymond Vaudé va aller
saboter un avion allemand oui c'est dans
le contexte du débarquement en Normandie
on est le 6 juin 1944 et donc il y a
l'aviation allemande qui souhaite
rejoindre les plages débarquement pour
empêcher l'apparition des trous de
l'année et en fait il y a deux avions
qui tombent en panne d'essence
l'avion était pour ainsi dire intact
monsieur Vaudé voulut l'incendier mais
les réservoirs étaient vides
île du temps donné ce projet c'est alors
qu'il m'aida à le saboter en crevant les
réservoirs on arrachant les câbles en
brisant les commandes et le mécanisme de
l'appareil et ceci pour le rendre le
plus inutilisable possible
c'est un avion qui aurait pu ravitailler
par de l'essence repartir en Normandie
et causer des décès en fait c'est des
actes qui ont pu sauver des vies
humaines ah oui c'est certain enfin
encore une fois le fait en plus de sa
beauté directement un appareil allemand
c'est à l'exécution immédiate
le 25 août 1944 Raymond Vaudé parachève
son œuvre de résistant en participant
activement à la libération de trois au
sein des FFI les Forces Françaises de
l'Intérieur en soutient des troupes
américaines
[Musique]
tous les faits d'armes de Raymond Vaudé
sont soigneusement consignés aux
Invalides à la chancellerie de l'Ordre
de la Libération
vous avez de la chance on a trouvé ce
monsieur vraiment Vaudé et pourquoi on a
de la chance parce que malheureusement
tous les résistants n'ont pas eu cette
décoration puisqu'on est à peu près à
65000 mais là il est la Résistance
française 65000 tout à fait don Raymond
Vaudé donc Raymond Vaudé très beau
dossier
après en quête du gouvernement le
ministère de l'Intérieur prononce un
avis favorable Raymond Vaudé reçoit la
prestigieuse médaille de la Résistance
et il obtient ce dont il rêvait depuis
son évasion sa réhabilitation
[Musique]
le parcours d'un ancien bannière qui
était rabbité par le général de Gaulle
pour fait de résistance je connais pas
d'autres
c'est un acte juridique c'est-à-dire que
c'est un document qui est signé ou par
le général de Gaulle et qui permettait
d'effacer toutes les condamnations
antérieures qui n'apparaissent plus dans
le casier le casier judiciaire
pour le coup c'est la rédemption
administrative oui tout à fait c'est le
tout final enfin
les documents peuvent encore apparaître
mais ils peuvent plus être cités avec
les condamnations enfin finalement il
est il n'est plus bannia non c'est une
nouvelle vie qui commence en efface ça
en tout cas toutes ces turpitudes
antérieures
en 1949 dans la revue détective la
nouvelle vie de l'ex bagnard Raymond
Vaudé fait les gros titres il est décrit
comme un garçon de café ponctuel
serviable et estimé de tous
[Musique]
le clan Vaudé c'était l'argi en 1940 il
s'est remarié avec Madeleine qui a déjà
un fils Claude née d'une première union
ensemble ils ont deux fils Jacky kiné en
1945 et Bernard en 1947 qui mourra bébé
mais Vaudé l'ex marin au long cours l'ex
bagnard l'ex résistant se sent à
l'étroit dans cette vie bien rangée
se lancent dans une nouvelle aventure
une expédition en Guyane cette terre
lointaine où il a vécu l'enfer qu'il
rêve désormais de transformer en
eldorado
Vaudé organise une conférence de presse
dans un grand café de 3
au journaliste et aux personnes tentées
par l'aventure ils décrit son plan
exploiter 80 000 hectares de terre
vierge dans la colonie qu'il décrit
comme la plus riche du monde grâce à ses
bois précieux et surtout son or un métal
abondant là-bas découvert au milieu des
années 1850 et qu'il obsède depuis son
évasion ratée dans la forêt tropicale 37
pépites d'or trouvées puis perdu dans
son périple le souvenir des pépites
entre mes rêves lors je le retrouverai
mais pas tout de suite plus tard dans
deux ans peut-être d'abord nous ferons
de la savane une grande terre fertile
des dizaines de familles embarquent pour
la Guyane elle rêve toutes de faire
fortune
Raymond Vaudé et son fils Jacky pose
fièrement à leur arrivée en Guyane en
mai 1949
[Musique]
à Cayenne un collectionneur passionné va
nous aider à reconstituer la suite de
l'histoire
bonjour bonjour
et son garçon comment vous regardez ça
parce que on voit que le bagnard est
devenu quasiment l'archétype du côlon
quand vos dés revient en Guyane dans
dans les années 40
c'est clair que c'est un bagnard pas
comme les autres il est dans une
démarche qui est pas celle du moment
quand il est il est déjà dans l'Hexagone
et il choisit de revenir oui et comment
vous l'expliquez ça
j'imagine connaissant le pays la
situation il voyait la Guyane comme une
terre de possible donc il est peut-être
plus colon quand il y a bagnard
effectivement
mais cet enthousiasme n'est pas partagé
par le gouvernement français qui
reproche déjà à vos dés sa folie des
grandeurs il convient d'examiner
attentivement les projets de Monsieur
vaudet l'affaire est insuffisamment
étudiée aucune disposition n'a été
prévue pour les charges de famille elle
aboutirait très rapidement à des
divergences et à des conflits
peu de temps après leur installation
dans la forêt tropicale comme l'avait
prévu l'État le rêve se transforme en
désillusion la nouvelle colonie
guyanaise imaginée par l'ex bagnard
n'existera jamais la ruée vers l'or est
un échec et pour de nombreuses familles
le coupable c'est vos dés
nous avons quitté l'affaire vaudée c'est
une véritable fumisterie
surtout qu'aucun copain ne se met en
route pour cette pauvre Guyane
avisez la presse c'est un devoir par
dessus tout
un journaliste écrit en juin 1949
c'est en réalité la fièvre de l'or qui
avait atteint les conquistadors
certaines familles réclamant vint le
remboursement des sommes engagées
désabusé elle rentre en métropole
odez lui il va faire quand même le choix
de rester en Guyane et il va il va
reprendre ce qui sait faire il était
cafetière à Troyes il va tenir plusieurs
restaurants successifs on le voit par
exemple sur cette sur cette carte
postale des années je sais pas
exactement
250 début 60 c'est le restaurant Beau
Rivage
Raymond et Mado en ce qui nous concerne
tout va bien depuis bientôt 12 ans que
nous sommes en Guyane n'avons jamais été
malade mais notre lutte a été dur enfin
nous avons réussi nous ne pourrons
jamais nous passer du beau soleil des
tropiques évidemment la France est belle
mais le froid nous en avons déjà le trou
du cul à 20 degrés en dessous de zéro
rien que d'y penser élégant jacky est un
phénomène il vient de fêter ses 16 ans
et il mesure 1 m 80
Raymond et Mado
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous avec la belle-fille et
les deux petits fils de Raymond Vaudé
dans un quartier cosu de Cayenne avec
eux on va découvrir comment l'ex
bannière est devenu en quelques années
un notable dans cette région française
de l'autre bout du monde
[Musique]
bonjour
ça va
[Musique]
les Vaudé j'ai une photo à vous montrer
plusieurs à vous montrer mais une
première j'aimerais que vous médiiez
et vous me disiez ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que d'abord vous la connaissez
cette photo
moi non jamais vu j'ai vu d'autres
photos mais je n'avais pas vu celle-ci
vous reconnaissez les gens oui bien sûr
vous me dites
pas mal l'enfant je pense
en 1964 Vaudé et restaurateurs et c'est
lui que la préfecture de Guyane choisie
pour préparer le banquet le plus
important de l'année
[Applaudissements]
nous avons à réaliser vous
[Musique]
sur place et la France avec vous une
grande oeuvre française en Guyane
et une grande œuvre dont on s'aperçoit
dans toute la région du monde où se
trouve le département
il faut qu'on le voit et qu'on le sache
partout nous avons commencé et nous
continuons
[Applaudissements]
l'ancien bagnard est résistant pose
fièrement aux côtés du général de Gaulle
l'homme qui l'avait réhabilité en 1947
Vaudé et désormais un homme respecté et
à 60 ans il se lance un dernier défi
[Musique]
participer à sa manière à l'aventure
spatiale à l'époque Kourou n’est encore
qu'un petit village
avec le sharamaka ils ont été les
premiers commerçants officiels de Kourou
et à ce titre ils étaient régulièrement
évités dès qu'il y avait une cérémonie
officielle
organisée par le sens spatial ils
étaient régulièrement invités en tant
que premier commerçant officiel de Corée
des vieux guyanais bien évidemment tout
de suite tout de suite ils évoquent ils
évoquent notre père et notre grand-père
et le grand-père et jamais de honte en
forme n'est pas ce truc de ton
grand-père
depuis fils de bagnard
les copains de l'époque on se voyait
avant une ambiance enfantine adolescente
était extraordinaire
[Musique]
50 ans après son ouverture le Sarah maca
existe encore
du Sarah maca dans les années 70 je
pense mais il y avait du soleil les
parasols mais c'est un peu ce genre là
quand même c'est en bas d'un immeuble
comme ça mais ils ont 12 pareil
[Musique]
depuis 1968 bonjour
alors les blancs
le nouveau propriétaire est un vieil
habitué n'ont pas oublié Raymond Vaudé
moi personnellement je l'ai pas connu
mais j'en ai tellement entendu parler
que
[Musique]
bagnard déjà bon ça comme un porte une
notoriété quand même
principal des choses et puis donc c'est
ce qui a permis un peu à la renommée
quoi parce que tu étais vraiment une
figure quand même c'était pas n'importe
qui de caractère aussi
effectivement il avait ses têtes pour
rentrer dans son restaurant il fallait
avoir une tête qui lui revenait sinon
vous étiez jeté bon m'a dit qu'il se
mettait parfois devant avec sa casquette
blanche éternelle
alors comment ça se passe il est là et
puis vous vois arriver bon alors ils
ronchonne un peu
un peu fort et là ben non il vous envoie
balader il n'avait pas envie de vous
voir et c'est quoi ces critères
et vous vous avez déjà été refusé non
non à chaque fois bon ça c'est bien
passé il y avait son épouse voilà
Madeleine qui faisait la cuisine et une
bonne cuisine familiale à l'époque
ici dans le département ça se trouvait
pas ça voilà ouais c'était le point de
ralliement de
ah oui c'était le seul point convivial
et si vous ayez pas réservé aux tables
c'était pas la peine ah oui oui c'était
un peu le début de l'âge d'or de Kourou
il est même contribué avec le restaurant
tous les gens qui gravitaient autour de
la base
technicien ingénieurs et tout le monde
venait venez manger là
est-ce que vous avez un souvenir en 79
du décollage d'Ariane donc selon vous le
pervaudé il est là oui il doit assister
à ça
[Musique]
m'a assisté aux deux grands événements
de la Guyane le bagne voilà et le
spatial et le spatial
c'est la bascule entre la première
appellation qui faisait peur à tout le
monde et c'est ça et maintenant le
spatial qui est quand même tire le pays
voilà l'avenir voilà voilà c'est ça 3 2
1 allez allez
[Musique]
alors vous avez quel âge aujourd'hui
Raymond Vaudé j'ai 75 et vous habitez à
Cayenne j'habite Kourou dans la base de
spatiale du coup
alors quel est votre vie aujourd'hui je
suis restaurateur mais je viens de
vendre alors maintenant je suis allé à
la pêche je crois que j'ai pas gagné un
petit peu le repos
les valises du bagne devenu une figure
de la Résistance avant de regagner la
Guyane meurt en 1986
Raymond Vaudé l'un de ses anonymes que
la grande histoire a oublié mais dont
vous connaissez désormais l'incroyable
destin
[Musique]